- Why would any human being
want somebody to burn out
and not be happy?
(calm music)
As I have more attention, I
feel a greater responsibility,
and so I become very passionate
about creating more context.
I think I'm at my best when I
have time to talk like this,
and I'm not when I'm too excited onstage
or in a one second clip.
I'm becoming more thoughtful
because I'm surprised
at the sheer level of quick
judgements that our society
has become comfortable with.
A lot of people out there
that really pretty much
live their lives based on
other peoples' opinions.
Like happiness and fulfillment
has to become a much bigger
part of the conversation
than financial upside.
I'm always very hurt when
people think that I'm pushing
hustle and too much work
and make it for the money.
You know, my behavior doesn't map to that.
I would've been a venture capitalist then.
Like I'm talking about
actually liking what you do.
There are plenty of interviews
in 2010 where my point
of view on Crush It
was make $86,000 a year
and talk about strawberries.
I've been talking about
happiness the whole time.
I have evolved and been
forced because I feel
like I've been dragged
into being a poster child
of something that I don't
believe in and creating clarity.
I'm very fascinated by the
conversation of work ethic,
hustle, overworking.
I'm fascinated by people's
ability to not take
on accountability.
I never feel like my points
of view and my thoughts
and my hot takes and my
passions and my story are right.
I've never believed that in my life.
I don't know if they're right.
I think I enjoy sharing them
because I enjoy sharing them.
I'm a communicator, but
everybody shares that.
I watch these conversations,
I'm fascinated by them.
I respect other people's points of view,
I just, I don't think,
I just want to make sure
that they don't think
they're right either.
A lot of people that push
against hard work, hustle,
are people who've already hustled
and didn't find fulfillment from it,
but maybe somebody else did.
Don't over judge yourself
in every chapter.
If you're like working
15 hours a day for a year
because you're starting
your videography business,
that's probably okay, it does
take work to start something.
If you've achieved some level
of success three years in
and you don't want to take
it to a $10,000,000 business
from a $3,000,000 business
because you fall in love
and you've started a family and you want
to play wiffle ball outside
with your child, that's amazing.
There is no right, there's
only right for you.
I think one of the biggest things we need
to get more thoughtful about
conversating with yourself
and trying to develop self-awareness
and not look for outside validation.
When people email me and say
Gary Vee, I've been hustling
15 hours a day, I'm like,
you getting enough rest?
You good? Like, are you pumped?
Like with intention?
My intention is to be happy,
and so I'm not gonna apologize
for enjoying my work.
- Has anybody called
you a minimalist before?
- No, but it's funny
that you just said that,
like I understand that
about me in some weird way.
When I think about anything
I buy, it's 100% for me.
Even all the chachkas,
the thrill of finding them
at a garage sale or like
the one thing I actually buy
that I think is silly is like
custom New York Jets jerseys,
but so for me, and it
feels very real to me.
Like I don't have outside
things kind of driving me,
and that's what leads me
to a lot of happiness.
I don't care about social
media, I really don't.
I care about humans
communicating with each other.
I'm fascinated by communication,
and I'm fascinated
that we now have a collective
ability to communicate
on a scale that we've never seen before,
and I think right now people are focusing
on the downside of that.
People need to try to be self aware about
what makes them happy and
doesn't make them happy.
Right now, social media, I
view social media as a mirror.
I think what people are
putting out is an incredible
indicator of what's inside of them.
So right now there's a
lot of political anxiety,
there's a lot of ideological anxiety,
and so what we're seeing
is a lot of judgment
or forgetting the upside.
There's so much love and
greatness going on everyday.
I think humans find what
they're looking for.
You're signing into
Twitter to find a fight,
you're gonna find it.
I think if you go to Twitter
or Instagram to find happiness
and positivity, it's there at scale.